الطموح السعي والتغيير انا منى قدوره
امراه عربيه تطمح للتغيير
[موسيقى]
القصه بدات لما كنت في الصف الرابع وبنت
خالي تخرجت ودرست تخصص الهندسه الكيميائيه
وهم سالتها اكثر عن هذا التخصص وايش
بيعملوا وعرفت انه التخصص له بتحويل الجو
ماتيريا ليسفل بروداكت وهنا حكيت انه هذا
ممكن التغيير اللي ممكن انا اساهم فيه لو
فهمت وعرفت كيف البروست بيمشي ممكن اني
اغير في البروستس ومن هون ومن اول صف رابع
لحد صف 12 وانا بدرس وبجتهد عشان احقق
حلمي وادرس هندسه كيميائيه في الجامعه
الامريكيه في الشارقه وتخرجت من المدرسه
وحصلت على المعدل اللي بتمناه وصحتني منحه
عبد الله الغرير وقدرت ادرس التخصص اللي
بريدته ولكن خلال دراستي للتخصص اكتشفت ان
البروسيس از كل شيء موجود وجاهز وصعب انه
الانسان يغير فيك ولكن خطير لي انه احنا
في عنا ماينار تخصص فرعيما انت الووتر
انجلينا فحكيت لحالي ليش ما ادرس ها
المايك الا لما يساعدني بطريقه اخرى اني
احقق حلمي واغير في
ضعف او الاشياء اللي موجوده
[موسيقى]
فدرست المايونير وتخرجت من الجامعه
الامريكيه مهندسه كيمياء مع ماينر امبيرنج
[موسيقى]
بالنسبه لاهلي كان دورهم كثير مهم جدا في
دعمي في هذه الجوعني لانه امم بدايه من
اختيار تخصص الهندسه يعني لما احكي لاي
حدا اني انا بدي ادرس هندسه بالنسبه لاهلي
اللي هو ايش بدك فيها هذه التخصص للرجال
مش للنساء يعني هتتعبي اللي حواليكي بس
اهلك يعني داعمين لالي واهلي يقدروا انه
هذا حلمي حلمي من انا وبصف رابع واهلي
شافوا التعب تبعي وشافوا كيف انه ما كانت
الجورني ابدا سهله وكانوا هم يعني المصدر
الاول والاخير للدعم وايضا مؤسسه عبد الله
الغرير يعني بتوفير هلا المنحه اللي
قدرتني اني ادرس التخصص اللي بدي اياها في
الجامعه اللي انا كنت بحلم فيها طول عمري
جوني تبعتي ما انتهت يعني انا لسه في
منتصف الجوني ولكن بعرف انه يوما ما راح
اوصل للدستنيشن الى الهدف اللي انا بدي
اياه وانا فخوره جدا انه الجوعني تبعتي مش
ثابته يعني مش هو هدفه وصلت له مش الي هو
انا بدي ادرس هندسه كيمياء في الجامعه
الامريكيه وصلت لها وخلص مش انه انا
اشتغلت
اوكي
هندسه
دائما احاول واجرب انه كيف ممكن
اغير وبدي تغيير ملحوظ وتغيير يكون انه
على مستوى العالم اني ااثر بغيري فان شاء
الله يعني مع الوقت راح اقدر اوصل لهذا
التغيير الي بحمل بحلم وبطنه حلمي اني انا
اكون نموذج لكل مراه عربيه
مكانها مش فقط في البيت المراه العربيه
قادره انها تعطي قادر انها هي تتحمل
الصعاب تخوض جميع المجالات تشتغل في
مجالات للس في المجالات اللي هي معروف
عنها ميلدا ومش فقط هيك قادره على الابداع
والعطاء انه احنا حتى مش كمرقه عربيه احنا
كشعب عربي مش اند يوز مش كنسيوم عز احنا
قادرين انه نحنا نغير قادرين على الابداع
وقادرين انه نحنا نكون نحنا اساس التغيير
ونغير الاشياء اللي بتدور حوالينا
[موسيقى]